tu as un stage de basket le week-end
prochain d'un super potentiel et je peux
t'entraîner
c'est pas ça que je veux pas
tu me laisses jamais joué comme je veux
jamais tu me laisse jouer mon style
où tu vas c'est pas le bon étage
je parie que will smith à peu ce genre
de galère
c'est quoi ce plan à la matrix
[Musique]
le bienvenu king james je suis au king
de ce domaine nous sommes dans le
serveur monde vous avez fait quoi mon
fils où est alors si tu veux récupérer
mon fils pour toi et moi on fasse un
petit match de basket vite en voix
masculine chez les loosers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi ce délire
sur cartoon et quoi de neuf de terre
je dois monter une équipe de choc pour
récupérer mon fils
mon chrono comme en cuir
elles t'ont la refaire s'il vous plaît
qui nice
bienvenue
au space
ce
[Applaudissements]
je vous présente le kun squad
tu dois gagner ce match
on va régler ça et récupérer notre fils
le coup classique
il fera moins mariole quand tu aurais
com quels espaces
mon
père